well here's here's the next big move we
got the story from cnbc spotify ceo
apologizes to staff for joe rogan
controversy as episodes get removed the
ceo said that it was joe who pulled the
episodes and they've gone on to announce
that they will be investing where is
this thing 100 million dollars the ceo
of spotify said they will invest 100
million dollars for the licensing
development and marketing of music and
audio content from historically
marginalized groups i don't know exactly
what that means but i can tell you this
if spotify takes 200 million dollars and
gives a hundred to joe rogan and a
hundred to historically marginalized
groups on the surface i could care less
more speech is better more speech is
good the problem is we're not getting
more speech
joe rogan is conceding and apologizing
and bending the knee and changing his
positions and the woke left is getting a
massive influx of cash so this is not
more speech it's the same old
establishment talking points and the one
show there's a reason why it's so big
joe rogan's show the the one the one
show with a big enough footprint that
actually move the needle that discusses
anti-establishment talking points is
bending the knee even if it's only a
little bit so we are not gaining in this
a lot of people pointed out when joe
said
i'll try my hardest to have you know if
i have one person who's controversial
i'll have another expert following him
it's like oh okay so the establishment
mainstream media which controls billions
of views per month that everyone's
already seen and the one guy the one
time gets a chance to speak out like dr
robert malone on this audience you're
gonna give the establishment the
rebuttal when they already own the
entire narrative i think the good it's
not a win the tactic is to have them on
together sanjay and malone and then the
truth will come out well rogan can be
some people have said you know
every all these all these you know
people are absolutely right joe should
not be platforming misinformation dr
fauci should go on his show for three
hours and explain everything in detail
wouldn't that be wonderful and then in
six months that'll be misinformation
it'll have to take it down well that's
you know that's the thing that's what
joe literally said in the first video he
made that a lot of the stuff that dr uh
malone and mccola talked about
a year ago would get you banned for so
he's not going to stop
then what happens is these activists
resurface a really old video a
compilation of out of context clips
and joe said he felt bad about and you
apologize for it the issue is
there's two fundamentally different
world views
joe is clearly of the world view that we
occupy that there are certain contexts
where describing things is okay
the other world view claims that joe
used the slur simply by uttering its
word in descriptive context joe does not
occupy that worldview although he's
claiming now he understands it and
agrees with them does he really agree
with them or is he scared of them
because i'll be completely honest
i completely will openly admit i
recognize there are conversations you
can't have you will get banned out right
joe is coming out and saying basically
that same thing that's why i'm kind of
like oh you know i kind of get it i
guess i i get it i used mean humor when
i was a kid it was kind of a part of our
friend group and we would call each
other really abusive names and like race
races and all this gross stuff and then
i learned somewhere in college i went to
theater school and it was very liberal
homosexuality was present and i learned
like
you can't just make fun of people
because of the way they are and i
stopped doing it and man has my life
become better i i don't have crap for
most part anything like i haven't done
the racist the the hateful not that it's
hateful comedy but the i haven't made
people butt of my jokes since since i
was 2001 or something edgy comedy was
all the rave in the 90s and 2000s and
now it's just
comedy is forbidden man well i mean it's
interesting too because especially in
the late 90s early 2000s all of the edgy
comedy was being done by left-wing
people who are trying to promote a
left-wing message and on some level i
think that's why they were so successful
in the culture war at that time
i think there's a simple solution to all
of this
for one
look joe's got a really big show and
that's why this news is getting so much
attention everyone is talking about it
it's getting bigger joe's apology video
made the story substantially larger his
second apology made it even larger it's
not going to go away unless or until you
know uh
this story is not going to stop until
joe's show is gone
for whatever reason either pulled off or
he quits because
you know they want the political
establishment they want him gone before
the midterms they can't have him
propping you know these voices or
anything like that
but i think
none of this in the end is is really
going to matter you know what matters
infrastructure infrastructure one of the
one of the challenges we face is that we
use youtube for one of our you know key
pieces of infrastructure the live
portion of the show a lot of people have
pointed out that we should use rumble
it's true the issue is rumble is a
fraction of a fraction of a fraction of
the audience that youtube has and while
a lot of people have said so what just
do rumble anyway
i don't think people realize
that i would say maybe like 70 percent
of the people who watch this show
are not super politically active people
they don't know what rumble is they
won't watch rumble they'll just be
confused one day as to why this show is
gone that's all they'll know it's gone
and i think it's against terms of
service of youtube if we run like an ad
from eight to ten on youtube that says
come to the rumble stream like they
don't you can't do it it's against terms
of service to tell people there's
there's clever things people do where
they'll stream for a minimum amount of
time and then announce they're doing a
stream somewhere else but if you like
youtube has a rule that if you announce
your streaming somewhere else and then
leave it's a bannable offense yeah
outright ban your whole channel also you
have to think about why youtube and
google are implementing a lot of these
different sensors censorship strategies
and the reason is because left-wing
activists complain to them and say
things like you're allowing this person
on this platform and often they'll say
you're allowing people to be radicalized
by this specific person on this platform
someone who's come to youtube for
reasons that are totally non-political
will see a timpool video or a freedom
tunes video or a crowder video and they
will get sucked on this deep dark rabbit
hole now what the person is really
saying is that other ideas are being
given a voice on this platform and i
don't like that for our response to be
you know what then we're just going to
get off their platform and give them
exactly what they want is in some ways
for us to admit defeat yeah it's like
there's a big battlefield and you know
the ranks are being flattened so we yell
retreat let's go see the battlefield
it's
and it's true i mean eventually yeah
youtube could ban each and every one of
our channels and i think it's important
to have a contingency plan uh for if and
when that happens but the fact that the
left wing is out there saying they're on
youtube and that's bad makes me very
much want to stay on youtube because i
want to do the things that the left
thinks are terrible so there's a couple
things to say one this is why we have
timcast.com so we can host you know
conversations in our quote-unquote
speakeasy but the other thing i'll say
is
if someone is here's what i tell people
they're like hey i want to get started
doing a podcast or whatever i'm like do
it on rumble don't start on youtube
rumble has for new channels in my
opinion an opportunity for growing an
audience faster than youtube does
and an opportunity for a style of
content that is greatly missing in the
market
i started making youtube videos as
content censorship was getting worse and
worse and worse here we are with a big
platform and a lot of people who watch
so i think it's important to maintain
but we do post everything to rumble as
well and for timcast.com we use rumble
infrastructure if you're starting a new
channel look at dan bongino dan mangino
had 2 million subscribers on rumble and
only like 700 or 800 000 on youtube so
for if you're starting a new channel i
would say start it on rumble and we've
talked about this too if you want to do
comedy
you can really do comedy on rumble the
links can be shared
then ultimately what it comes down to is
it's not about joe it's not about any
individual it's about infrastructure
it's about the ability of individuals to
freely speak without any without having
to be uh to worry about being banned
so in the event we ever did get banned
oh yeah we'd immediately be on you know
rumble most likely
but uh you know they're not perfect
either we'd still operate much the same
way and you know we probably just carry
on but there'll be a lot of people who
would be genuinely confused to what
happened to the show that you know
youtube will probably lose some
viewership but man i got to tell you
when we are sick or we have a
cancellation and so the show doesn't
happen we can post about why doesn't
happen everywhere and we still get
emails from people saying like where's
the show i even get facebook messages
from fam like where's the show and i'm
like man we literally post it on twitter
on instagram on youtube like we post it
all over the place and people don't see
it they just turn on the tv at eight
turn it off at 10. basically a lot of
people tell me they turn on their tv
open the youtube app and then watch the
show live on their tvs and we've also
seen a whole bunch of images that was
really funny i think luke it was luke he
was browsing amazon remember this yeah
yeah he was browsing amazon looking at
tvs to buy and one of the tvs had a
product description like photos and the
photo was us on the tv is really really
funny so meta so so anyway look the
point is
we're we're we're beholden to youtube
for a lot of ways but i like to imagine
that we have we have extended some kind
of bridge from youtube to rumble to to
bit shoot to gab to minds to any other
of his other platforms where people can
still communicate and share
so my advice is anyone starting new
channels rumble is your opportunity not
just i'm very interested in integrating
mines in rumble it's it's on the talking
table right now i've been hanging out
with chris and bill and i'm like
obsessed with this i want to put it
together i want to bring andrew come on
in buddy i know over there gab i see you
uh i love you andrew i think integrating
gab mines and uh
rumble and library is so key and right
there in front of us very excited that's
like one of the things we do is we like
you know the candidates that we work
with and a lot of the uh you know
organizations we work with are you know
the big tech censorship's a very
important issue to them and so like when
we work with the canada we want to steer
like we want to steer them towards you
know when we get this new gop majority
we actually have to do something change
laws in congress that can prevent big
tech from sense from politically motive
from doing politically motivated
censorship
and you know because of the lobbying
budgets they have that's why it's never
been done because a lot of you know
unfortunately it's a lot of republicans
who take money from these companies and
then laws are never changed and the
censorship continues is there a way to
get that money out of politics
uh well no no because we have citizens
because we have the citizens united case
where corporations are considered people
and they have free speech so you know
there are campaign finance laws like the
fec has like laws but you know there are
ways like there are ways around it just
as their ways around you know billion
like rich people when they pay their
taxes
yeah so we have to repeal what was it
called uh citizens united that's the
name of the supreme court case but you
know it's a supreme court overturn it
it's very tough to repeal that
yeah it's a it's a it's a precedent
basically allows super pacs to spend it
comes from way back in the 1800s a guy a
really rich guy wanted to run for
president had all this money he's like
why can't i use my own money on my own
campaign i want to take a train around
the us and they're like he's kind of
making a good point and that was the
first step of like hey rich guy
gets to do politics it's a little easier
so they start passing laws to kind of
aid the wealthy after that
yeah but i mean
what i think is that the gop has changed
a lot on the issue of big tech and i
think we're starting to see them get a
lot more serious you know with with on
that issue and i you know
when we get this new gop majority in
this new midterm election that should be
that's that's an issue they need to
focus on yeah they talk about breaking
up big tech i don't think you can break
up the corporation that's why i talk
about freeing the software code of big
social networks i wonder if it's too
fascist to order the government to but
it's kind of like breaking up a monopoly
well yeah i mean our anti-trust law is
fascist
i don't think so they're like
anti-fascist
yeah it depends on who you ask i guess
look i think i think
if you're like a liberal i mean i think
i would say most libertarians would be
against that sort of thing but i would
say
as you know i as somebody on the as a
conservative as somebody i distrust if
you distrust
you know concentrated power in the
government you should also distrust
concentrated powering corporations and i
think one of the things people on the
right
you know miss today is that government
today is is not the only threat to our
liberty corporations that get too big
can be just as big of a threat and even
more of a threat like what would you say
is a bigger threat to your freedom today
the government or google yeah i know
exactly
yeah
it's wild the military
uh concerns me but a corporation can
hire private military basically it can
have armed security and then if they
want to flick a switch and go psycho
you're like well glad we have a
government to protect us thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you